Dave neighbors having a woman that won't
bleed you dry and keep your neck up in
debt is important absolutely that's the
one thing like what a lot of girls their
lifestyle is so like a lot of my friends
it's it's like I make more money than
them but they live like such an
expensive lifestyle like they all have
fake long nails like which which are
they they add up it's like 200 like
they'll go to nice places it's 200 bucks
every time they go roughly or 150 to 200
because they're Nails in there and then
on top of that like if they get lash
extensions if they get BOTOX if they get
friends your age are getting Botox
um these are more girls that I can just
tell on the show that they've had it the
girl the girls my age don't Botox not
yet but I there's yeah it's a shame
Botox lip fillers like yeah it fake hair
oh don't even think yeah and it's just
like how would you in a a family like
maintain that because it's like unless
you do really well which what percent of
girls are gonna get the opportunity to
be with a guy that does really really
what some will but it's not the majority
so the majority are gonna have to date
and I don't want to say have to like
it's a bad thing like the majority will
date average man and marry average men
if they get married at all so
how are you gonna afford that with kids
you can't first of all it's fake and
second of all the men don't like that
you know men want you they want to know
what they're going to they want to see
you in every environment you know can
you swim can you you know get in the the
carpool can you you know be active all
of that is an expense and a lot of times
you know women we do that for each other
I shouldn't say we but you know you want
to present yourself well but you want to
do it in a way that's sustainable what
men value I've heard you all can chime
in is consistency and the problem with a
lot of that elaborate put on first of
all they don't like it but it requires
so much maintenance and then you go from
looking like you're going on the runway
to who shot John so you know find a
routine that works for you and make sure
that you know number one your man likes
it because ultimately I don't care how
many compliments I get from women if my
man says I don't like your hair like
that I don't do my hair like that
because ultimately his opinion trumps
you know what everybody else would say
and that's like
that's like that is very much like him
before me which is you know how it
should be but it's not common nowadays
yeah and I understand you know and I
kind of got caught up in that you know
thinking it was a partnership but the
problem is and I told you this yesterday
and especially at my age at 47 it
happened after two kids at 35 40 you
really feel yourself as a woman like
okay you know what I kind of want to
slow it down I want to set it down and I
was one of those in my 20s I thought I
could do everything a man could do
compare that to the men that I know at
my age they are putting it in second
gear they're starting businesses they're
investing they kind of have this like
I'm running out of time I want to go
hard so
I you know how you say
women shouldn't vote because they don't
have to go to war yeah so for me it's
kind of the same thing if I am not going
to carry the same load until 65. oh I
should submit because he's willing to do
what I'm not
so true because
I never that is such a good point
because a lot of times people say well I
make more than him now
yeah or or I out earn him how could I
submit but at the end of the day they're
going to work longer than us absolutely
I mean if you look at it I know we like
to idolize some women that have it but
how many older women do you know are
still going just as hard in their 50s
think about that right I really that is
such a good point so even the ones that
we admire you know I don't want to drop
any names but you all know the ones that
are really really
um well to do they start stepping back
in their own way but if you look at the
men that are really wealthy you know
they are opening new businesses and you
know acquiring more things and so that
is I feel like the value that having the
older women speak to the younger women
it's like I see myself in you but I also
see you know Maggie at 60 and I'm making
decisions now that it's going to make
that period of time a joyous one oh my
gosh that reminds me of my dad because
he retired tired and he sold his
business and he's just starting a new
one exactly it's like they exactly how
many men do you know that retire from
their job I told you about my dad
yesterday and they stay at home for a
few months and they just like they got
Cabin Fever they can't do it my dad's a
retired teacher a PhD he's a you know
retired teacher and he stayed at home
for a little bit and now he's a real
substitute teacher every time they call
him he's back in the classroom whereas
my mom on the other hand she is ready to
just you know slow it down enjoy the
grandkids and grow old gracefully so
that's what's coming that's such a
that's such a good point I never thought
of that what what else should be on here
oh dear so we talked about money so we
talked about did we talk about
intimacy since you were talking about
body count I think um no but let me put
it on here intimacy right I mean that's
an important part of
um the marriage it's how you connect
with each other and I know you talked
about body count I think isn't it Sex
and Money the two big reasons why
marriage fails marriages fail so I think
that's something that you should address
head on and the couple should agree on
what's important to them so what does
that mean
well intimacy specifically means you
know your drive does it match oh do they
have equal like right sex drives right
and even if you don't are you willing to
be you know available to your husband if
we're talking about women if he
is interested more than you are you
really just have to kind of have those
conversations we get the ring we get so
excited we want the big day and then the
honeymoon is over and you're looking at
him and he's looking at you and you're
like oh man what did I get myself into
but you really need to talk about all of
it
what else
oh dear all right so we talked about
food we talked about money we talked
about family we talked about work
[Music]
um
I know communication is
um one of those words that's kind of
like what does that mean but I think
communication styles are important for
example I don't know if it was you or I
was telling somebody else I know my
um triggers or difficult conversations
and I will still have them but as a
woman because I'm emotional I can tell
my guy okay this is a little hard for me
I need a moment it could be an hour it
could be 24 hours I will come back and
have this conversation but I want to do
it from a place of being level-headed
and not have an emotional response I do
that too if I'm really mad about
something I my mom always told me to
wait two days yep and she said if you're
still mad after two days you can talk to
them but like if you just wait because
like especially if we're close to our
time of the month or like where we are
in our cycle like there's very many
times where I've been so mad and I woke
up and I was like wow I was overreacting
and I was so glad I didn't like say
anything her or talk to them because
it's like if I if I did then I would
have maybe said something I regret and
like just sometimes like waiting is like
the best thing you can do as a woman
because we're currently you know there's
a part of every girl that's a bit crazy
and sometimes you gotta you gotta take
care of that yes and it's okay just
admitting that and knowing that but it's
not okay to just act it out well I feel
this way so I'm gonna do this no I feel
this way I want to do this but I have a
brain so I'm going to wait and I will
you know come back but just give me a
moment and we need to understand how men
communicate because they are very direct
and they give direction and sometimes
it's a little harsh but when you know
you have a good one and he loves you you
just need to be able to take that listen
to what he's saying and not get so
concerned about the tone because they
communicate differently from us so I
think that's important to talk about
what what else are we missing oh dear
let's see
um we talked about money communication
what other things do people have issues
with
um I would talk about like social
including social media
um so your expectations for your friend
group and your presence on the internet
what you're gonna share what you're not
gonna share with us no that's such a
great that's such a great comic because
I've actually like
I I feel like I've been in a public
relationship before and I I actually
would prefer to like not tell people
about that at all until like like I I
feel like people always ask me about
like who I'm dating and like all this
but it's just like I feel like it's just
no like I just rather nobody know until
I'm married once I'm married you can
know who he is like yeah but it's just
like because I've and I don't know if
that's it would also you know it depends
on the guy too like yes but it's like
I don't know I just I've been in a
public relationship before and it caused
so many problems because you're worried
about what people say oh yeah and what
people think and it's just I I hated
that it's it's not worth it there is no
benefit it's just basically feeding
people's curiosity but at the end of the
day it doesn't change anything about
your relationship so I would 100 percent
uh recommend that it's private
especially when you have a platform like
this because not everybody wants the
best for you and they'll smile in your
face but then you know look for ways to
undermine and being in relationship can
be hard enough especially when you're
just starting and you want to have a
good foundation I keep my relationship
private and I think the happiest people
that I know we found out when they
wanted us to know and not a moment
sooner
what would you say
um
for girls because a lot of girls get mad
their boyfriends won't post them do you
think that's a reasonable thing to be
mad about absolutely not I think he
should embrace if he wants to protect
you
see and that's such a that's so much
better of like a mindset than because in
all honesty I I used to get mad about
that like like when I was younger me too
and then it's just like I didn't realize
that he was doing it because of the
problems that like came with it later
yeah and in all honesty like in
hindsight I like realized I was wrong
about that because it's like
I don't know it's just it I saw the
problems that came with it yeah the way
that men look at the world they operate
like the enemy is always at the gate
they are looking ahead at what's going
to happen after and as women we often
think about the moment right we think
about oh it's going to feel so good to
be claimed to be spoken for I want that
you know I went through the same thing
where it was kind of like ah why do we
have to keep this quiet but I held it
together and I'm so happy now especially
having a public platform that you know
nobody needs to know because you can ask
yourself okay are we making we make a
post we are what do they call it
Instagram public or Facebook public and
then what
everybody that you know is going to have
an opinion about it so then you're going
to find yourself explaining for
analyzing every interaction I mean you
see it all the time on I mean I do it
first I do it sometimes you know like on
social media like Will and Jada
they were the perfect couple and now
everyone over analyzes every little
thing absolutely you know just like the
two ladies that share their body count
whether your body count is high or low I
would recommend keep it very low why
does anybody need to know that moment
that little thrill that you got that I
have 27 people that I've slept with or
five people that I've slept with now
that it's out there in the universe
universe how is that helping you you
know and we're talking about Kevin
Samuels what he always used to ask what
does that past bring the future husband
that you want so there are some things
you just need to take to the Grave
wow
what else on here all right we talked
about social media so we have social
media on here but I would also add like
friend groups oh because where do you
think oh I was gonna ask this earlier as
women
we need to talk about our problems more
than men absolutely would you agree with
that so when something's frustrating us
I feel like sometimes men it's this is a
fight that I feel like I see happen and
it's like a very much like the Sexes
don't understand each other because
women we want to talk about our problems
right and men want to solve them all the
time so we if we go to the men they get
frustrated absolutely because and it
because they're like well you're not
asking me to solve it but at the same
time the men don't understand why don't
you just not talk about it right and
where where do you think women should go
to talk about their problems so a couple
of things you definitely need a group of
other women that want to hear all the
details if you want to share them but
also want you to win so it's really
important to have that group that's
another project that I'm working on we
can talk about later if you want to but
you have to understand the way that men
think and if you are going to talk to
him I would reverse the order so if
you're asking him to make a decision
lead with that so sometimes I'll tell my
guy
I don't know let's say something at work
happened you know I will say you know
should I do should I travel for this
meeting or should I stay home and then
all the reasons why I think it might be
a good thing or or a bad thing sometimes
as women we give all that detail and men
are looking for how do I how do I
think of a couple times right so
them you can even use that in the
business world like even in a meeting
like set an agenda the purpose of this
meeting is or what I want to be able to
do after this meeting is make a go no-go
decision try to operate that way and
just understand if a man doesn't want
all of that it's not that he loves you
any less it's just that it's a burden
that he can't do anything with so help
him help you so find some girlfriends if
you must to talk about it but if you are
going to talk to your man lead first and
then ask him do you want the detail he
may say no and be okay with that
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible